oh I remember these I remember these all
right cool whatever I'm ready
what type of pasta do penguins eat
the penguini
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right there my name is Daniel this
is snack Wars UK versus us for lead
Bible
[Laughter]
they're violating on Twitter they
violate us us London has they call us
beans on toast people like Americans but
yeah a bit cool after beans and toast a
lot it's more to us
we've got those are just back here yeah
I'm more of that Aramaic I'm trying to
add like more onions and curry powder
onions a bit of garlic powder and all
kind of things
so this is kind of like this is kind of
like you mean would you would you do
cheese on them
back in the day
but
um no I don't do cheese now so what and
then back this as well now so this is
yes
so we've got a American fluffer Nutter
and peanut butter which is apparently
quite like this so it's like marshmallow
fluff so it's marshmallow like basically
in like spread form spread form yeah
Americans have a crazy stuff I remember
it was I went to I went to Coachella one
time when we hitchhiked to ride back
yeah and this goes in the car with this
guy yeah and then like he was like oh
yeah they have like grape favorite
flavored apples
no
wait so did you try one yeah
and it basically tastes like it's a
texture of an apple with a but it's like
great perfume
all right so then this is all right holy
shrimp
[Music]
hey mother
I want to go for another bite
I'll go for this one yeah
because I love peanut butter
that is crunchy as well I love peanut
butter but this is basic because it has
no aromatic has no love great flavor so
do they just like genetically modify
that or do they just that's so gym
yeah there's so much GM stuff it's
really fun everything's fake
[Music]
is this you're not seen this before
all right cool
all right cool wine gums Maria Wang gum
man you know I'm more of a Jelly Baby
syrup
what color did you get go for it
that's the thing about this this is Long
Island I enjoy this man I'm trying to be
here with you all the time
[Laughter]
oh it's like a hard-boiled sweet
was it yeah
[Music]
people are weird
awesome that's too weird bro that's too
weird that's not enough
I don't even like wearing guns yeah
that's too much oh there's kiwi let me
try to kill you
don't just use that no
right up
Buzz
that that's it waste exactly what it
says in ways
I didn't see that one what was that
kisses
penguin penguin
penguins
get up out of the years
chocolate bars
I used to sell triples no triples
triples and gold bars remember gold bars
yeah yeah just so gold bars and it was
like a joke on the penguin oh I remember
these I remember these all right cool
everyone ready
what type of pasta do penguins eat
Monroe please
penguini
I'm here all month
the orange one you should be the one
it's a pen wasn't bad I think was a big
fan
consistency chocolatey
jokes writers
I buy a lot of jokes
[Music]
I don't like that so this is Hershey's
kisses and up
oh that was supposed to make me easier
a lot of chocolate
penguin penguin yeah because it's just
more it's not biscuiting yeah do you
want to see what like maybe the next
penguin joke is all right see if they
can redeem themselves ready
why was The Penguin's head so cold
because he was wearing an ice cap
Hershey's
[Laughter]
have you seen this before I've heard of
it I've never tried it
what is this
indulges in this apparently I think Jim
used to have it a lot as a kid didn't
you as a kid so what happened who who
did that to you my dad so what so we're
like What did he what would he do what
is it is
[Music]
normally you can
I read today that it's been going since
the Middle Ages what is dandela
dandelions so they used to just like
mash up dandelions and like roots
burdock root and make it into a drink
and now it's still going to the stay
Bon appetitive
foreign
[Laughter]
numbers
sometimes you need them eventually
the American version of the fruit based
drink
[Music]
this reminds me of Florida
when I was a kid went to Disneyland you
know it's Disneyland and then like we
went to McDonald's in it so it's like
McDonald's but you can like refill
so then we got the thing and we just
went crazy we just went and the fries
were like that big like we just went
crazy and there's a root beer and no
caffeine
this one you know sugar yeah nice that
was better the USA one
GMO
thank you
if I had objection I mean it's
incredible
you didn't have any watches that's what
it's from no watches no knickknacks
Diego what's this ain't no knickknacks
they bringing the big guns yeah I'm
making a big gun so it's like what are
you like are you gonna have a snack
without what's this
and monster Munch come on man it's Herod
Heritage yeah I mean heritage
you did proper tradition like this don't
do it don't do it oh God don't have to
do it do it do it
I got you oh oh God